amniocentesis is a procedure that lets
doctors detect or rule out problems with
your baby's health long before birth in
the uterus your baby is surrounded by
amniotic fluid that provides protection
and nourishment floating in the fluid
ourselves from your baby providing
doctors with genetic material for
testing in amniocentesis your doctor
will take a sample of this fluid to test
for specific genetic disorders and birth
defects amniocentesis is usually done in
the second trimester of pregnancy at
fifteen to eighteen weeks
it is generally offered to women with
certain risk factors age 35 or older
which increases the risk of chromosomal
disorders such as Down syndrome a
previous child or pregnancy with a birth
defect blood test or ultrasound
suggesting a birth defect such as Down
syndrome or neural tube defects or a
family history of genetic disorders such
as cystic fibrosis amniocentesis may
also be done in the third trimester
for these reasons to determine if the
baby's lungs are mature enough should
early delivery become necessary to
diagnose a uterine infection or to check
for anaemia in a baby with Rh
incompatibility to begin your procedure
your doctor would use ultrasound to
create an image of the fetus and nearby
structures on a computer screen looking
at this image the doctor can choose a
safe place to insert the needle your
doctor may give you an injection of
local anesthesia to numb the surface of
your abdomen where the amniocentesis
needle is to be inserted carefully
watching the ultrasound monitor to avoid
contact with the placenta or the baby
your doctor will introduce the thin
needle through your abdominal wall into
your uterus and into the amniotic sac he
or she will then withdraw a small sample
of amniotic fluid remove the needle and
cover the site with a bandage your body
will make additional fluid to replace
what was removed
we'll continue to monitor the ultrasound
to check that the fetal heartbeat is
normal and the baby tolerated the
procedure well you may feel mild
cramping or pressure in your lower
abdomen
for about 24 hours after your procedure
you will be advised to avoid physical
stress such as vigorous exercise lifting
prolonged standing and sexual activity